i'm so thrilled mandy moore is
pregnant with her first child
i feel very lucky the 36 year old
actress announced the wonderful news on
thursday that she's expecting a baby boy
with her husband of nearly two years
taylor goldsmith pretty crazy in these
stunning black and white photos posted
to instagram
the couple is all smiles as taylor
caresses mandy's baby bump
and the caption baby boy goldsmith
coming early
2021
here are the expecting parents
performing together at an event for
this is us last
my year were forgivable
[Music]
taylor is a member of the band dawes and
according to the candy singer he's been
a huge influence on bringing music
back into her life most importantly
mandy moore is back in the music studio
i'm writing i just like i i think i've
been inspired from
the music that i get to sing on the show
but also like my fiance is a musician
there's
constantly like there's music in our
lives every single day
he's always writing we started writing
together not too long ago
and something just flipped in me not
only is she a beloved singer but mandy
is also known for her
emmy nominated role as rebecca on this
is us
when you're a mom you get a front row
seat to the best show in town
watching your kids grow up in 2017
mandy opened up to e.t about how her
relationship with taylor
came at the perfect moment in her life
it seems like taylor is so much a part
of this happy new chapter of course
i don't think i would have found myself
in a happy and healthy relationship had
i not done the work on myself first like
i needed to get there
uh before being completely open and
ready to to find
you know the love that i've been lucky
enough to find i definitely
don't think that we would have found
each other before i was ready to
to do that work so much of it is timing
sometimes all timing